hello everyone and welcome to some uh
very exciting news from the super United
Blitz tournament currently being played
in Zagreb Croatia Magnus has defeated
everyone yes I'm sure you've already
heard it as you do have access to the
internet Magnus has achieved the perfect
day and although it is not considered a
Bobby Fischer prize because even though
he's a nine out of nine it's not the end
of the tournament there are still nine
more more rounds and uh something that I
did not know if someone wins all of the
games as Magnus is doing here uh he will
receive the the so-called Bobby Fisher
Price which is uh sixty four thousand
dollars I guess they made it that way
sort of a thousand dollars for each
Square on the chessboard which is um
well Magnus said in an interview after
this game that he probably played the
the best chess he ever played and that
he doesn't think that he will be able to
repeat this success ever again but who
knows tomorrow is a new day I will see
what happens so let's see how he
defeated Constantinople who is having a
a rough tournament but he is the the
lowest seed of the tournament so it is
uh well it is within a reason to expect
that uh so let's see uh how it went uh
Constantine has the white pieces and he
opened with the four magnets went for
Knight to F6 C4 E6 Knight to C3 and he
goes for Pawn to D5 the Queen's Gambit
declined uh and Constantine goes for the
exchange variation captures captures and
Bishop to G5 we have Bishop D7 E3 and
now standard moves here are castles in
C6 but Magnus goes for Pawn to H6 which
is extremely rare only a handful of
games but Magnus himself already played
it this year uh in the Tata steel
Masters tournament against a very strong
Grandmaster Parham aksulu and he
defeated him with the black pieces so
here we have uh Bishop to H4 now comes
Bishop to G4 and in that game a queen
day for check was played by Max Lulu but
here now we have just Bishop T2 blocking
this attack and it is now already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game and this is a exactly what Magnus
wants if he's to play one more game for
a win and it's very hard you're on 8 out
of eight so of course even if you lose
even if you draw you are leading the
tournament chances are you will be doing
very well but you kind of want to you or
you are that close to nine out of nine
you really want to make a nine out of
nine and the Oscar said during his
commentary that you know if someone
asked him uh in in the first round with
what are the chances of Magnus winning
this with nine out of nine he said of
course zero but now that you're on eight
out of eight you're kind of hoping for a
nine out of nine so Bishop captures
Knight G captures I need to and just
Pawn to C6 we have Castles by both
players and now Queen to C2 Constantine
playing uh very nice here we have rook
d8 and now Rook 8 to E1 Knight B to D7
nicely continuing development and F3
adding support for E4 later on Pawn to
B5 by Magnus and now King to H1 always a
useful prophylactic idea Rook C8
preparing Pawn to C5 and now Rook to D
E1 we have Pawn to B4 uh Knight to a for
now guarding the C5 square and the
Magnus does advance at Pawn to C5 the
queen is under C2 so it makes sense D
captures Knight captures and now Bishop
captures on F6 uh Knight captures an A4
Queen captures Bishop captures and now
Knight to F4 and here we have Rook
captures on E3 Knight captures on D5
attacking The Rook uh ended the bishop
and Rook the E2 but now Constantine
plays this beautiful Knight to C3
attacks the queen and the Rook on E2 but
Magnus had all of this planned he plays
Queen to E8 and attacks the undefended
queen on A4 I say undefended because if
the Rook is captured then the queen is
undefended so here you should uh capture
on B4 or trade Queens uh Constantine
doesn't want to play this active looking
game with the Rook on E2 against Magnus
so he decides to trade Queens Queen
captures we have Rook e captures back on
E8 as The Rook was hanging here and now
you have to move the Knight Knights the
D5 again attacks the bishop and the B
for pawn and while you could go for
something like captures captures and
it's probably something 99 of players
would do not Magnus he trades uh this
beautiful bishop and his King side
structure uh for activity as this is
Blitz and activity matters most he plays
Rook to see too now he wants to play
Rook 8 to E2 and then put pressure on
the white king and then it will be very
difficult to defend of course the
position is still very much a draw but
with little time on the clock it's hard
to defend Knight captures on B4 Rook
captures on B2 and now again Knights to
D5 because this will come with check and
now Rook e to E2 putting pressure on the
G2 Pawn but of course Constantin will
grab the bishop with check first first
messing up magnus's Pawn structure and
just play Rook to G1 Magnus plays Rook
captures on A2 and now we have this rook
and king end game Rook and pawn end game
where Magnus has a past a pawn so this
is again a draw but you have to be very
careful and you only have one active
Rook this one unfortunately has to
remain here to guard the G2 Pawn so
Magnus has all the moves in the world
and Constantine really left with Rook B1
Rook D1 Rook B1 Rook D1 or if you can
you know try to create something with
one rock so he doesn't want to play
Passive he goes for Rook to D7 uh and
now just Pawn to A5 of course he wants
to put the Rook behind the pass Pawn
which is what you always want to do
whether you're attacking or defending
and now King to G7 Magnus starts making
his way uh over to the white king upon
the H3 Pawn to H5 King to H2 and now
Pawn to H4 uh stopping the king from
entering the game Rook to C7 and now
Rook the F2 Magnus with the thread of
Rook captures and F2 as the g-pawn is
now pinned and not a lot of good waste
uh go about this uh well you could
defend it with something like Rook to C3
then you're very past you're just gonna
wait for Magnus to finish all of all of
his moves and then you will probably
lose the game uh some some way so
Constantin decides to go active he gives
up the F3 Pawn for the H4 Pawn which
will give his King a bit more room to
breed uh Magnus goes for it Rook
captures on F3 Rook to G4 check first
king to f8 and now Rook captures an H4
we have Ponte F5 by Magnus and now Rook
back to C4 we have came to G7 and
Constantine unfortunately has to move
the Rook back and forth Rook to D4 we
have Pawn to F4 King to H1 and now of
course this is a threat so you move the
Rook Rook F2 F2 but Magnus was planning
to play this either way as he needs to
get this Pawn all the way to F3 the idea
is F3 captures and Rook to H2 checkmate
it of course so Rook to D3 and now Pawn
to A4 Magnus continues pushing forward
Rook to C3 and now King to F6 we have
Rook to D3 and now Pawn to A3 Rook to B3
and only Now Pawn to F3 once all the
pieces have been put to the right place
uh Rook captures on F3 but I mean there
isn't anything better Rook captures G
captures and here Magnus just plays Rook
the B2 and he was in this position on
move 45 that Constantine lupuscu
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is the
white king is on the back Rank and there
is no defense against A2 and Rook to B1
it doesn't matter what you play if Rook
day one just A2 the white king cannot go
up the board whatever you play next move
is Rook B1 check you have to trade and
he will get a queen into the game and
other moves aren't much better or
whatever you play Rook to G for again A2
is coming and there's no defense if you
play a rook day for now same thing Ruby
one checking goes up the board and you
get a queen uh he will have to give up
The Rook for for the queen and that's it
so yeah a really incredible Magnus uh
plays a very weird a very weird line
with this uh not weird but it's not
played as often with this H6 move really
an offbeat approach but he already
defeated maxulu in classical so he
thought oh why not let's try it against
he probably has some sneaky moves uh
already and he made a very very
practical decision here uh if you guys
remember when we reached this position
where uh after this Knight the D5 move
was played he played Rook to C2 instead
of going for well the natural looking
Bishop captures and Knight captures
because who would give up the this
beautiful Bishop no one well no one
except Magnus he went for activity and
then it all worked out for him because
this uh with little time on the clock
for your opponent this just is worth
more than an active Bishop obviously if
you're a Magnus Carson so what can we
learn from this uh play uh all the all
the great moves uh you know in all the
positions and you will be the greatest
players in the world the Magnus finishes
with nine out of nine tomorrow is a new
day will can he make it 18 out of 18 uh
No One Believes that but no one believed
he could do 9 out of nine so we'll see
what happens tomorrow so yeah those were
the games I hope you guys enjoyed it was
pretty much a one-man show Magnus
finishes I don't want to trick you guys
let me just check the standings but I
believe three points ahead of everyone
let me just quickly check
uh yeah Magnus with 20 out of 27 then
Fabi with 17 out of 27 nipple with 17
out of 27. so Fabian nipple are going at
it back to back from the rapid section
it's just that Magnus just completely
crushed everyone then alireza with 15
out of 27 and Roberta with 13 and a half
out of 27 and so on and so on so
basically uh what we will see tomorrow
is a fight for second place I don't
think anyone will be fighting for first
place Magnus we'll win this uh unless I
mean I don't know what what has to
happen but it's basically a fight for
second place uh so I once again really
hope you enjoyed this uh treat by Magnus
it's uh you know a a gift to all the
chess lovers so hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
John Austin Paul Miller Brad Roth and uh
Michael Marshall for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestion and whatever else happens in
the Chess World but mostly covering the
final day of the super United rapid and
Blitz tournament uh being played in
Croatia so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and if you still haven't seen the
simultaneous exhibition by Young Ivano
mochic against every player of the grand
Chester do check it out first link in
the description below see you soon